this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace more on them at the end of
this video now over to Grant what's up
guys my name is Grant Stevens and it's
been a while since I made a video on
this channel and in the process of this
me and Adam were thinking of what would
be a good crossover topic between my
content that's predominantly martial
arts focused and the regular audience of
the bioneer and in doing that we came up
with the idea to do a more broader video
about the benefits of martial arts
training and how you might like to
incorporate some of this into your
regular training plan so the first part
of this video is going to be me
essentially trying to sell you the idea
of starting to practice some martial
arts which I believe is beneficial
whether you're a complete beginner or
somebody who's already quite experienced
in training and then if that pequs your
interest I've included a shadow boxing
workout for you guys to get started so I
personally feel that martial arts
training is an activity that's
completely unique and nothing else
really compares to it so to The Outsider
it can often just appear to be another
Dynamic Sport with lots of movement like
tennis or basketball but really if
you've practiced any martial arts you'll
know that it's so much more than that
and it goes without saying that it's a
fantastic way to improve your physical
fitness it enhances strength endurance
flexibility balance and coordination and
these are just some of the surface level
benefits combat sports are really unique
in that you're able to train all three
of your energy systems as well so we've
got the Anor robic alactic which is high
intensity for short durations the
anerobic lactic which is high to medium
intensity with a decent Tempo anerobic
that's low intensity for longer
durations the benefits also extend to
things like improve mental discipline
stress reduction better confidence
better focus and these carry over to
improved productivity and attentiveness
in work school or in your personal
relationships it's also a great way to
enter a flow State due to the
combination of mental concentration
combined with physical challenge and it
just gets you really in touch with your
body helping you to improve your mind
muscle connection that's going to
benefit your efficiency in other
activities like weightlifting for
example one of the main areas I would
like to highlight for those who already
train is cardio now cardio tends to be
viewed as kind of a necessary evil and
many people end up doing something that
they don't really like or enjoy just to
tick that box and this is where I would
suggest including some martial arts
training the main reason for this is
because on the surface this training
just kind of looks like you're moving
your body but it differs in the sense
that martial arts training is this like
big skill that's made up of a lot of
other skill sets which something like
jogging on a treadmill just doesn't have
so you get the dual benefit of building
a skill while incidentally getting a
great full body workout at the same time
and you essentially don't even realize
that you're actually training the best
thing about this is is that you can
begin from any level and just go at your
own pace building as your tolerance
increases and I think this gives it a
much broader appeal and something very
taxing like hit which is great if you're
somebody extremely serious about
training but those people are in quite a
minority compared to the general
population and I think many people new
to training can feel quite overwhelmed
by this which can result in them being
intimidated and just not even starting
in the first place so My Philosophy is
basically if it gets you moving then
it's something that's good to do martial
arts training is performance-based over
Aesthetics and it might not be for
everyone but it's so easy to get caught
up in nowadays which at some point is
going to detract from performance
because of this the conditioning around
the activity becomes purposeful like in
a video game where you select the type
of character you wish to play as and
then you have to grind to level up those
specific skill sets and there are so
many gratifying ways to train as well so
what this comes down to is really what
someone's actually capable of doing is
much more important than what they look
like they can do but even then it's
certainly not mutually exclusive it's
not like training in martial arts means
you're going to look like trash you're
not going to end up looking like Arie by
any means but this is my physique which
is purely from doing martial arts style
training and just a sensible diet and I
would argue that the majority of people
actually desire a physique like this
rather than that of a massive
bodybuilder and on that note as well
martial arts training is something that
has constant progression and if you're
training for Aesthetics what happens
when you reach that desired physique I
personally feel the goal of improving
your performance is much more satisfying
and is generally the sentiment of most
of the audience on this channel so those
are just some of my feelings and the
benefits that you can expect from
martial arts training but now we're
going to move on to the actual practical
training part of the video now I'm going
to give a simple breakdown of how to get
started with this style of training and
incorporate it into your routines and
although my area is predominantly
martial arts I'll be focusing upon only
hand techniques in this part because
there's a much lower barrier to entry
and kicking is quite difficult and
complex with that being said if you're
already an established martial artist
then feel free to add leg techniques as
you please the best thing about this is
that you can choose your own level of
involvement and many people feel quite
intimidated when thinking about this
type of training and feel too
self-conscious at the gym so if that's
you then the base level entry is
literally Shadow Boxing in your bedroom
which if done with sufficient intensity
can be a fantastic workout the
foundation techniques in boxing
correlate to the numbers one to six and
I suggest you focus upon these
predominantly number one is the
jab number two is the cross or straight
right number three is the lead
hook number four is the rear
hook number five is the lead upper
cut and number six is the rear upper cut
having good technique is really
important especially as you begin to
progress and I will be giving some
points as in this video but I don't want
to focus too heavily on it so it becomes
a barrier to getting started if you are
interested in diving deeper into this
topic though this is what my channel is
all about and I have an in-depth Shadow
Boxing guide on there that I think
you'll find beneficial the main things
to keep in mind are relaxation and
remaining balanced in your stance
without Distributing the weight too
heavily on either leg when neutral be
mindful to keep your hands in a guarded
position to protect you especially
during the extension of the arms when
you throw a punch and then always return
into this position when you're not
striking you want to keep composure in
the body when moving and punching to
ensure you're able to use your energy
efficiently in the strikes ensure you're
rotating through the hips and shoulders
when you strike as opposed to just
punching with the arms and lastly be
sure not to rush through the punches and
complete the full movement especially
when moving at greater speeds this
generally means to ensure you're fully
extending your arms into the punches so
those were a list of some of the basic
fundamental principles that you want to
be aware of when you start doing this
type of training but this does take a
long time to integrate so don't expect
Perfection from the start in a moment
I'm going to walk you through an example
Shadow boxing workout consisting of five
3 minute rounds with a 1 minute break in
between each and you can use this app
that I use and find really helpful where
you can program round times and breaks
to your own specifications now during
the 3 minute rounds I suggest slightly
upping the punch frequency in intensity
after each minute until you moving close
to full intensity by the final minute
frequency meaning how often you execute
punches from your neutral stance and
intensity meaning the level of intent
that you execute each of the techniques
with what this doesn't mean is
continually standing on the spot just
striking aimlessly without rest try to
get used to moving around naturally and
perform some evasive maneuvers while
imagining an opponent throwing strikes
towards you and then striking
intermittently so after a brief warmup
of your choice I really like skipping
because it's very similar to the
activity itself you want to perform some
dynamic stretches to loosen off the body
paying attention to the shoulders hips
and the neck round one consists of some
combinations including the one two or
jab cross and some combinations using
these punches are as follows the simple
jab
cross
double jab
cross jab cross jab Cross or four
straight
punches so begin slowly just getting a
feel for the techniques and then up the
intensity and frequency as you progress
through the round round two consists of
adding Hooks and uppercuts to the
straight punch Combos and some of these
could be lead hook rear uppercut lead
uppercut
rear uppercut lead
hook lead upper cut rear
hook Again Begin slowly ensuring you're
moving the body into each strike and not
punching only from the arms and then
increase the intensity as the round
progresses round three we're going to
add in some defensive Maneuvers so
practice executing some Combos and then
evading counterattacks thrown by an
imaginary opponent and some examples of
those are jab cross slip
cross uppercut hook cross and weaving
out the weight of an opponent's
Counterattack a good way to think of
this round is to always ensure you're
moving out of the way after you've
completed your punches round four is a
combination of everything we've done so
far at a moderate pace so not totally
relaxed but not full out and try to keep
the combos two to four hits maximum some
examples could be jab cross
hook slip rear uppercut hook
cross slip cross
hook slip lead hook cross
be creative and try to follow natural
sequences of punches which means in
combos following the first punch the
subsequent punches make sense to throw
because your body is already aligned and
in position for them and finally round
five is combining everything that we've
done so far at a quite intense pace and
the combos can be as long as you want
but within reason so don't throw 15 hit
combinations you'll definitely begin to
fatigue during this round but when that
happens try to keep moving and maintain
composure in your stance when you've
caught your breath back then resume but
don't just stop and stand stationary so
that's kind of a basic workout structure
that you can use or tailor to fit your
own specifications for instance you
could make speed and punch volume the
focus of the workout taking the power
out of the strikes but instead throw in
a greater number of quick and snappy
punches or the alternative in that you
think less about volume and speed but
instead focus on power delivering fewer
but more powerful blows once you're
relatively competent with this type of
training I would suggest progressing
this workout onto to something like a
heavy back this adds a whole new
dimension to the way you move and
essentially forces you to improve your
Technique by better applying your weight
behind the punches in order to transfer
power into the target which is something
that you don't need to do when only
Shadow Boxing but other than that there
are so many different options that you
can do with this like training with a
friend holding pads Etc so you know just
remember to have fun and be creative
with it so I hope you enjoyed that guys
and I've convinced at least some of you
to incorporate this style of training
into your regular workouts please be
sure to visit and subscribe to my
channel over at youtube.com/ Steven ma
it's more heavily focused upon martial
arts training so for those of you who
are interested in learning more about
this type of training then I've got a
lot of relevant videos there thank you
for watching and I'll see you next
time just like everyone can benefit from
practicing some martial arts everyone
can benefit from a website whether
you're an entrepreneur looking to make
money online a professional who needs an
online portfolio and business card or
you're just looking for a unique way to
express yourself creatively Squarespace
is a website site building platform that
makes it extremely easy for anyone to
get started pick a basic template drag
and drop elements where you want them
and you'll have a professional and
modern looking website running in
minutes no coding required though simple
Squarespace is extremely powerful with
all the tools and features you could
need for any kind of project for
bloggers there are Advanced formatting
and Publishing tools not to mention a
fully integrated commenting system with
threaded comments replies and likes
there's gated members only content if
you want to gain some extra revenue from
your W in or why not set up a shop with
the powerful e-commerce features using
third party plugins you can even add
more features like Inventory management
and global Shipping everyone from
hairdressers to personal trainers will
benefit from appointment scheduling and
the social media integration is perfect
for building out your community to learn
more head over to squarespace.com and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com bioner for 10% of your
first domain or website thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring the video
thanks to Grant from making it thanks to
you guys for watching and bye for
now